Lee Harvey Oswald is a lone nut with
some psychopathy and whatever mental
issues he had that that doesn't feel
right right so you got to add elements
you know so the KGB and the FBI and the
CIA the Cubans and the models you're
just cranking it up like like the Jack
of a car until it's the causes are match
the effect
this is Star Talk Cosmic queries Edition
Neil deGrasse Tyson here your personal
astrophysicist I got with me my co-host
Chuck Nice Jack hey Neil how's it going
welcome back on for for another episode
of cosmic queries yes
inquiring minds want to know
and the title of this one is why do
people believe conspiracies why do they
want to believe conspiracies that's what
we really should call it oh do we need a
whole episode for that because I think
we do right now okay it's called stupid
they're stupid stupid people
we live okay we're done here
thank you good night
all right anyway we have I guess one of
the leading if there was a patron saint
of Skeptics yes this man Michael Sherman
Michael welcome back to StarTalk
yeah it's a good start well you know if
the intelligence is distributed in a
bell curve by definition half of them
are below the mean so yeah you may be
right except for like we'll be gone
where everywhere everyone's above normal
yes yeah yeah so let me just get a
little your bio out here founding
publisher of skeptic magazine yes and
you've got your own uh podcast the
Michael Shermer show I've been on
multiple times thanks for inviting me uh
you're you're a presidential fellow at
Chapman University where is Chapman
University
orange Anaheim Southern California and
you have degrees in Psychology
experimental psychology and in the
history of science very important topic
there History of Science and cool you've
got a book this fall uh titled
conspiracy colon why the rational
believe the irrational you see good
thing Chuck didn't write that book
because he just said you ain't rational
if you believe it my book would have
been called conspiracy what's up dumbass
there you go
all right so so Michael I love my soul's
response oh boy
he's like it's going to be a long show
so so I I you are deep in in this topic
your whole life yeah I mean it's a
career you're a career skeptic and I
just want to uh just enter on on Common
Ground here with you there are people
who might say
uh I don't believe the claims of
vaccines because I'm a skeptic
right and so at what point do you say no
you're not a skeptic you're actually
ignoring evidence at what point because
they might think that they're trained to
be skeptical of everything they hear how
do you help those people
right that's the rub because nobody
thinks that they are believing nonsense
no one joins a cult you know people join
groups that they think are good you know
no one in the history of the world is
ever self-identified as a
pseudoscientist going down to their
pseudo lab to collect pseudo facts to
support their pseudo theories right they
think they're on to something and so the
question is what does it mean to be a
skeptic really it's following the
evidence and when there's enough
evidence to kind of tip the scales into
belief with a small B in the truth with
a small T when there's a consensus you
can say yeah okay so it's all accepted
as provisionally true I'll be willing to
change my mind if the evidence changes
but for now I accept the Big Bang Theory
of uh in the theory of evolution The
Germ theory of disease global warming is
real vaccines do not cause autism you
know and and are helpful for public
health and so on so none of these are
based on arguments from Authority it's
that I know the scientific process works
in a way that scientists themselves are
competitive and they push it each other
to higher levels of evidentiary
standards and so by the time it trickles
down to me I'm not a climate scientist
but you know if most climate scientists
tell me that you know global warming is
human caused and real it's reasonable to
accept it because of all the competitive
uh push and pull in the process to get
there in the first place right so in the
case of conspiracies it's it's a little
bit different because
um conspiracy theories are ideas about
conspiracies which is defined as two or
more people plotting in secret to gain
an unfair illegal or immoral advantage
over somebody else or some other group
and that happens all the time right so
it's not unreasonable for people to
think I I said I'm suspicious that
something might be up because it happens
often enough in the real world Corporate
America corporations you know cheat to
to dodge the regulatory state or
government agencies do things because
they don't tell you
that brings up a a very um
interesting question for me
okay conspiracies are legitimate as a as
conspiracies but if they are done in
secret
then how is it that you're
how can you convince somebody that the
secret has been exposed or that there
was no secret to begin with
hmm
right well so you do have to have
evidence uh so not all conspiracy
theories are equal which ones have
evidence or not and what would you
predict for evidence so for example
um if uh Wikileaks showed you know
millions and millions of classified
documents leaked to the public not one
mention of 911 as an inside job not one
mention of the uh hoaxed moon landing
and where it was filmed and you know no
memos about that or you know or just
take your pick you would expect in a
leakage like that like with the Pentagon
papers we found out all kinds of things
that the government was lying about but
none of them had to do with the moon
landing or anything like that it was
like they lied about the Vietnam War
well okay that's not exactly shocking
governments do lie to their citizens
right but you would predict if something
one of these other conspiracy theories
that are popular were true there would
be some evidence for it in a leakage
like that there you go so so Michael in
your book you you you speak passionately
well you speak personally in many places
but the one that that struck me was uh
when you commented about the reaction of
people to your uh 911 analysis that
appeared in Scientific American Magazine
I mean Scientific American is as as
pedigreed a place as you'd ever find the
writings of Science and could you just
tell us a little bit about people's
reaction to you
right so there I I wrote about this one
of the little memes going around that uh
you know that steel melts at
2700 degrees I think it is and the jet
fuel only Burns at like 1800 degrees
therefore no melting steel no collapsed
buildings they must have used uh
internal explosive devices you know
demolition intentional demolition who
who did this it must have been the Bush
Administration and and you're off and
running anyway I just pointed out I
called that Fahrenheit 277. you don't
have to actually melt steel all the way
right right you only have to weaken it
they don't melt the Horseshoe to reshape
it right it just has to become malleable
so that no longer can support the weight
of the structure itself don't melt
horseshoes
that's right right right and those
buildings are heavy I mean they're each
floor is really heavy right so and and
from there then it's it's actually a
nice test case of how you know if a
conspiracy theory is likely to be true
or false how many elements would have to
be involved come together just perfectly
in the in perfect coordination for it to
happen how many people would have to be
involved you know to plant explosive
devices in a building you have to break
through the drywall and wrap this
structural support beams in in these
explosive devices there must have been
hundreds of them in each of the two
buildings two of the most secure
buildings in the entire world after the
Al Qaeda tried to bomb at 93 right so
how did they get in there oh well they
were there under the pretense of
elevator repair oh elevator repair then
why are they nowhere near the elevators
planning these explosive devices right
and also they would have had to know
exactly which floors that the planes
were going to hit ahead of time to put
the explosive devices on those floors
because that's where the the buildings
collapsed at they this collab started at
that those floors you're giving rational
facts right why why are they even
relevant and by the way also there's the
most rational fact
s Administration
come on
yes right so and the people that believe
this by the way also think this is the
most incompetent uh presidential
Administration we've ever had and
somehow they pulled off the most
sophisticated conspiracy of all time
right exactly and no one that was
involved wants to go on 60 Minutes and
write a tell-all book or somebody that
knows somebody
um that was one and become wealthy
independently wealthy defense for us
right for having done so
let's get to our questions because we
know I don't want to ask questions that
I know we got people who are asking so
Chuck what do you have lined up all
right so this is Michael here this first
question Michael looks all comfortable
in his chair there he loves watching my
Captain's game that's great that's a
good chair
let's let's see if we can destabilize
this chair with these questions okay go
so this first question is from a Super
Fan named Chuck nice he says
Chuck are these patreon members and are
you still not a patreon member you don't
have to ask questions oh that's right
okay I do have a question though I want
to ask is it's a personal question for
uh for Michael but I'll I'll get to our
patreon Members First here we go Kevin
December yeah Kevin assembly says uh do
most conspiracy theories get conjured up
because of Hollywood films or is it more
the mistrust of government or is it a
combination of the two
well it's a combination of the two and
many other factors as well politics
plays a role but in general if a film
comes out that's very popular like JFK
and
91. retelling yeah I mean it was a
well-made film I mean it's compelling
you know back and to the left back and
to the left Kevin Costner is repeating
this and he's like oh my God he must
have got shot from the front right and
uh until you dissect the film and you
you pull out all the mistakes and errors
and exaggerations and incorrect uh
inferences and so on there's really not
much there but yeah so films drive it
make it popular for a while I mean there
were some actual studies done after JFK
was released in which the percentage of
people that suspected the government or
somebody was involved besides Lee Harvey
Oswald went way up it's like it was it's
always been above 50 since the Warren
report this is kind of the mother of all
conspiracy theories it never dips below
50 but after the film it got bumped up
so you know I have a whole chapter on
that because that it's one want
everyone's so interested in there's a
whole industry of books and films about
it yeah but Michael you commented that
that World War One began in a bit of a
had some conspiracy routes to it and
that's before we have modern media even
before films mattered right so right so
yeah there must be something deeper
within us that's not so much slave to
media that we still want to make this
happen right because conspiracy theories
go all the way back to ancient Rome
right the the plot to to kill Caesar and
so forth that or when or when Rome
burned there were conspiracy theories
about uh you know Nero made it happen on
purpose my Hopper he let it happen on
purpose lie hop right this is a very old
idea even uh you know Roosevelt was
accused of letting Pearl Harbor right be
bomb over making it happen on purpose
just to get us into the war right yeah
yeah because why else would line up the
ships that way like like sitting ducks
for their bombers right because if I
call this everybody if if there's one
thing we all know about America is we
will resist getting into a war at all
costs
see I call this I call this instead of
my Hopper or ly hop I call this cowhop
capitalized on what happened on purpose
right so it's not that bush orchestrated
911 or let 911 happen but he certainly
capitalized on it right to follow his
own agenda as did Roosevelt absolutely
wanted to get the United States into the
war to support Great Britain against
Germany couldn't do it without some uh
event and that was the event so
politicians do do that oh you know and
and they do so in secret often you know
and and you know I have all chapters on
all the shenanigans the CIA has been up
to in the 50s 60s and 70s you know MK
Ultra you know dosing U.S citizens with
LSD and other mind control drugs because
we didn't want to fall behind the
Russians and the Chinese and the North
Koreans and mind control technology or
you know planting
um spies in social justice organizations
like aim the American Indian movement
family are you telling me we fell behind
in a mind control Gap
just exactly like there was a missile
Gap there was a fear that we're behind
the Russians on mind control there's a
mind control Gap yeah but it turns out
the Russians were making us think that
we were behind all along
don't get meta on me now Chuck
that's actually a thing Chuck that's a
you know an agent of disinformation you
know they're purposely uh you know
leaking information that's false that
sends us down the wrong track UFOs are
subject to that you know that there's a
lot of people that think that the
government is very amused by all the
talk of uaps and UFOs because it
distracts the public from what they're
really doing whatever that may be right
right right
wow God all right here we go this is uh
Stephen Somers uh Stephen says greetings
stargazers uh please what are the top
three cognitive biases that prevent
intelligent people from making
intelligent choices yeah so this is this
is the core of the subtitle of your book
where you make the Assumption contrary
to Chuck's book that he hasn't written
Yet Michael you you are you are granting
the person
the the power of rational thought
and then posing the question how does a
rational person believe in such a thing
so
so where is the where does the
rationality get driven off the cliff
well in fact back to where we started
with Chuck's comment about intelligence
in fact intelligent people are really
good at rationalizing beliefs that they
hold for non-intelligent reasons that is
to say most of us believe all sorts of
things that we didn't arrive at through
evidence and rationality and smart
people are really good at that the
confirmation bias only seeking
confirming evidence for what you already
believe and ignoring the disconfirming
evidence the hindsight bias after
something happens it seems obvious why
it happened and we should have known it
happened like the August 9th 2001 Memo
from Condoleezza Rice you know Al Qaeda
to strike U.S on U.S soil how come the
Bush Administration didn't do anything
about that well because there were 10
000 pieces of Intel every week about
what Al Qaeda was up to and you know
only after the fact do we go oh that's
the one I mean you know this but I just
want to add because I I come from the
universe here that for the shuttle
disasters right right you once you have
the disaster you then look and find the
memo from an engineer about the opening
launch for those reasons right and for
successful launches you don't engage in
that same search where you might find as
many or possibly even more memos that
give just the same kind of warning it's
it's very simple it happens to everybody
uh probably on a daily basis let's just
say for instance you're about to drive
to work and you say should I take Elm
Street or should I take Pine Street and
because you had that thought of the
choice between Elm and pine you get on
Pine Street it's backed up you
automatically say to yourself I knew I
should have taken
you say that I knew I should have taken
L Street something told me to take Elm
Street no what you did was you equally
weighed both and decided on one but in
hindsight the other seems like it was
your choice because otherwise you know
you're just stupid
exactly so hindsight price sounds pretty
pernicious but the the questioner asks
is there a third bias that we put at the
top of this list oh well just let me
just Riff on that one more time because
um and by the way Chuck Elm Street was
one of the streets that the Kennedy uh
that JFK turned off of onto to into the
dealy Plaza so interesting you picked
that one I wonder if that was random I
should have turned on Oak Street instead
yeah okay
exactly actually Mike Michael before we
get your third bias and before you flush
out what you just said I'm going to take
a quick break and when we come back more
with Michael Shermer he's got a new book
out on conspiracy theories and why
rational people might think irrationally
about them we'll be right back on Star
Talk
we're back StarTalk Cosmic queries
Michael Shermer patron saint of Skeptics
not only on Earth but Across the
Universe I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
and I Michael is an atheist so for me to
call him patron saint of anything uh so
I mean I mean that in a in a in a
metaphorical sense Michael I don't mean
I don't think he's a man just be a
patron saint
so Michael the question was uh what are
the three top uh cognitive biases that
would lead someone to think uh
conspiratorially and we left off with
the hindsight bias which is particularly
pernicious right what else you have
going there well then also
um we we missed the events that didn't
happen so there's no conspiracy theories
about Hinckley shooting Reagan because
Reagan survived Eddie died he very
likely they would have very likely been
you know conspiracy theories about who
was really behind Hinckley besides that
you know mental illness something like
that the third one I'd say
proportionality bias it is we we want to
proportion causes and effects they
should be roughly equal if you take a
little Stone and hear some Physics for
you uh and you throw it you know a
little bit it doesn't go very far if you
throw it you know hard it'll go much
farther so we think of cause and effects
you know if I put a lot of effort if you
ask subjects to roll a dice and and try
to get a low number they kind of throw
the dice gently if you want them to get
a high number they really throw the dice
oh yes yeah yeah oh my God it's
hilarious really funny oh my God they
gently if you gently drop the dice oh my
God I'm gonna get a one or a two no I
want a five or a six right uh so uh in
terms of conspiracy theories if a big
event happens So Reagan survives so okay
it wasn't that big of a thing but uh JFK
didn't so what's the cause of of
Kennedy's uh death it's got to be the
most powerful person in the western
world has got to be something equal
right so Lee Harvey Oswald there's a lot
low nut with some psychopathy and
whatever mental issues he had that that
doesn't feel right right so you got to
add elements you know so the KGB and the
FBI and the CIA the Cubans and the mind
you're just cranking it up like to make
sure I have a car until it's the cause
is if you think about that you know the
Holocaust the Holocaust one of the worst
things that's ever happened in human
history committed by one of the worst
political regimes of all time the Nazis
that there's a kind of a cognitive
balance there uh or just take say 911
you know you telling me 19 guys with box
cutters managed to pull this off this is
the kind of thing you hear now it had to
be something massively big because it
was massively big or Princess Diana
cause of death drunk driving speeding no
seat belts right tens of thousands of
people die of in automobile accidents
for those three reasons but princesses
are not supposed to die by the same way
that the rest of us die right so you
know it had to be the royal family and
Prince Charles
right yeah
yeah oh man so proportionality I have to
go there you have to go come on you know
that that's that's still a big deal like
everybody yeah it was like you know once
you go black the royal family kills you
you know like that's tough I mean you
know come on that doesn't even rhyme
Chuck
it's my newest it's not even a saying
it's not a thing it is now
so Michael
um we we mentioned JFK mentioned 911
um is are there conspiracies like the
mothers of all conspiracies that we can
learn the best lessons from so that we
can then walk away and apply it to our
Thanksgiving dinner and any other
conversations we we might encounter well
let's just take the rigged election
conspiracy theory you know when he's you
know you and I take it yes were you
being any young man
I'm like please yeah please take it take
it take it anywhere just take it you can
throw it in the dumpster
well okay so first of all you know
there's always election anomalies if you
go and search for them we call that
anomaly hunting and uh and in other
countries there are rigged elections I
mean the CIA famously was involved in
rigging elections in South American
countries in favor of fascist dictators
over communist dictators because at
least they'd be friendlier to U.S
industrial interests right business
interests and so on our RP our
government did that right so it's not
unusual for people it's not unreasonable
for people to be a little suspicious of
that and if you look in past elections
almost every time the every every losing
party thinks that the other party was up
to something there were some Shenanigans
there in Ohio or there was some quirky
thing in Iowa and so on oh by the way I
just because it's fresh in my head I
recently saw Citizen Kane and in it uh
Kane runs for office and but is caught
in a trist and so he loses popularity he
ends up losing the election
and but he controls the newspaper so the
next morning's headline was
that the election was rigged uh against
him interesting yeah
yeah wow nothing citizen came
oh my God what an interesting tidbit of
trivia
nothing new Under the Sun I guess yeah I
know right these things are old and go
way back okay so well what's the what's
the take home here how do you know what
to believe what's true what's Justified
true belief the definition of knowledge
well the Justified part well how am I
going to determine if I don't know what
that van was doing at three in the
morning when it pulled up behind that
building in in Georgia somewhere and
there was a grainy video of this and you
can't quite make out what's going on but
it looks like they were bringing in
boxes of votes maybe there was something
to it I wouldn't even know who to call
right so I uh but but so you have to
have some trust in institutions that do
confirm these things that do look into
these things right so when attorney
general Bill Barr appointed by Trump
himself and who is a lifelong Republican
and who would be motivated to find some
kind of fraud
couldn't find any and said we didn't
find anything the election was totally
legit that should have been the end of
the story when Society is normally
structured in a way where you trust
institutions like that but that's not
the world we live in at the moment you
know people don't trust science like
they used to or the CDC or scientists or
professors and they certainly don't
trust politicians anymore so that's
right save that for the third segment
because we want to know we need some
positive thoughts at the end of this how
do we rebuild confidence in institutions
uh but I want to save that for the third
segment Chuck why don't you give me
another question okay let's go to Rude
Van Der Linden rude says hello Neil
hello Chuck hello Michael rude from the
Netherlands here I've got a question
scientific research after covet
indicated that people in countries where
government trust was not was high got
vaccinated more often if this is true
for misinformation as well does high
distrust equate to more misinformation
circulating or you know he's basically
is is there a proliferation of
misinformation uh when the ground is
fertilized by mistrust basically is what
he's saying yeah indeed it is right as
the example I just gave if you don't
trust any voting institutions to run a
legitimate election no one's going to
believe it so I am worried about that
and Chuck what's a common fertilizer but
you know bull poop [ __ ] obviously
I'm sorry I said it I'm sorry you said
fertilize you said fertilizing right
yeah however I mean that just begs the
question then
um why don't I believe like if you're
talking about an election
why don't I believe that it was rigged
when my guy won if the whole thing is
crap to begin with
so if you don't trust the institutions
that means the institution of
um elections are uh right so very
important question there right and this
is this is the it's I I only complain
about the umps when they're right when
they call a strike against Mighty
against my team right right right yeah
that's called the my side bias it's
certainly quite strong we notice yeah
Michael has names for him
it is so great
I wish I was that fluent man that's my
side bias you you cosmologist and
astrophysics you're not the only one to
have cool names
every sporting fan probably yeah to my
side bias even though they don't want to
but so what normally happens though in
previous elections is that after a while
the losing side drops the conspiracy
conspiracy theory and they start
focusing on the next election this is
unusual what we're going through now
we're or Trump has kept it alive and
only because he still has some political
pull in the GOP uh or any is anybody
saying that there's anything to it we
know from the January 6 hearings that
none of the top people believed the
rigged election they believed Barr when
Barr said there was nothing to it then
that was it but wouldn't the conspiracy
be Barr has been bought out or how he's
there there is a yeah there is a
conspiracy theory about just to maintain
the thought you have to keep going at
the conflicting dates right yeah that's
right never liked him
they got to him they don't know just as
I do so do you we all know okay it's
always and it's always there isn't it
they did it they yeah it was the day who
is that right who are they right they
killed Kennedy who the CIA Who and the
CIA who did it right
you know and this is so again another
one of these you know how do you know if
a conspiracy theory is true or not is
you know can you act if it was a
criminal trial could you even get a
grand jury to agree to try this person
is there enough evidence pointing to
that certainly for Lee Harvey Oswald
unquestionably but who else if there's a
conspiracy who else was involved and and
no one has ever come they've come up
with something like 214 different names
but there's no evidence for any of them
I think there was like 42 organizations
and 214 different people who were
involved in the assassination of Kennedy
I mean you know it would you'd fill up a
stadium full of people that had to be
involved and not again not one of them
wants to talk about it or no leaked
memos about it nothing like that right
so yeah my side bias and and those kinds
of things are are very powerful normally
the sides move on but um not not at the
moment fantastic all right well this is
Cicero artifan and Cicero artist what a
name oh my gosh right no that's that's
the name of an artist in the Louvre
something exactly that's not anybody's
real name this afternoon we shall be uh
surveying The Works of Cicero artifan
um yes
all right the very first artist to take
cubism and impressionism and put them
together
all right here we go Cicero officer
conspiracy isn't that great oh by the
way just a quick thing I had an occasion
to have a chat with Rob Reiner recently
meet him from from
All in the Family yeah anyway so I don't
know if he did this we had an idea was
brilliant he said imagine that there's
he was going to make a movie where
there's this big uh institution with big
columns on it and stairs that lead up to
it and it's just called they
that's funny and so so well they say
that really and then you go in there and
this is whole set of committees and the
typewriters going away and out comes a
statement they say
and that's it's a it's the place where
they communicate with the rest of us
that's pretty funny actually that's
pretty funny I like it okay so what else
you got Cicero artifan says uh hi uh Dr
Tyson hi uh Dr Shermer and Hello Lord
nice Cicero from Toronto Canada here
um what kind of questions should I make
when I'm dealing with a situation that I
would like to avoid being biased on an
issue so how do we how do we self-assess
to make sure that we are not falling
prey to all these wonderful biases that
you have pointed out to us
hear the mirror yeah how do you because
if I think if like you said Michael if
you think you're rational like you said
no one ever said I'm going to my
pseudoscience lab to find pseudoscience
results so that I can be a pseudos no
one says that so how do you self-check
that might be impossible at some level
um well it's not impossible because it
does happen we know that scientists are
subject to all these same biases but
they can't let themselves get away with
it because their colleagues will call
them out on it right so you have to
think if I was reading my paper here or
my research as a Critic what errors
would I find what mistakes of reasoning
would I uh see that I personally can't
see so you have to kind of mind read you
have to put yourself in somebody else's
but you also have to check your ego at
the door right or or just have my mother
as your mother don't worry
she will tell you all the stuff you did
wrong
and every single place you failed
Chuck has continued his therapy sessions
into Star Talk programming
so you have issues with your mother okay
yeah a whole other thing yeah just don't
don't Edge them on Michael just let let
that run oh I'll tell you what you
should do Chuck you should go to your
local Scientology Center and tell them
this while you're holding the little
cans doing the uh the eater readings and
tell them about your mother oh they will
they'll have a course for you to take
ten thousand dollars it's only ten Grand
okay
what about yeah yeah what a bug okay
couple other questions you can ask
yourself like what would it take to
change my mind because almost nobody
tries to dis kind of falsify their own
beliefs it's almost impossible to do
people find a pattern and then they find
search evidence to fit it Michael
agreement with that I've attempted that
in a few cases and it really puts people
back on their heels without use coming
across as being aggressive right if you
just say and what they're quick to say
well what would change your mind but I
don't go into that question unless I
have an entire Litany of things that
would change my mind and so there's
research by a psychologist Peter Wasson
so this is one of the Wasson tests so if
you give subjects like a series of
numbers like two four six what is the
rule so people go I think the rule is
probably increasing numbers by two even
numbers so then they'll go like all
right 10 12 14 and the guy goes yep
that's correct okay 56 58.60 yep that's
right and they'll think oh well that's
it that's the rule and it's like no
that's not the rule and no one ever says
like well one seven thirteen and the
rule is something very simple just
increasing numbers that's it yeah
sequence of right but no one tries to
falsify it you know they go well I think
I figured it out it's two four six so
it's increasing even numbers by two
that's the rule why didn't you ask some
other sequence just to see if that would
violate the rule and so Watson's
conclusion was is we only try to confirm
a hypotheses it's it's very difficult to
get people to try to falsify their
hypotheses and this is what you have to
do okay wow I like that that is that's
tremendous I mean that and what a I mean
that's an exercise I don't think many
people are going to want to engage in
because one it's it's it's it's arduous
it's really tough on your on your own
psyche and and right chuck if I say
convince yourself that you're not funny
my response would be uh there are
audiences all over the world who have
done that for you
but whether or not that's true you'll
come back to me say FU too
it's a tough tough thing to do okay okay
man this I gotta tell you this is a
great show everybody in this country
needs to be watching this show okay all
right here we go uh this is
Alejandro Reynoso
it's rich Corinthian leather
let me guess it remind he's from Ponte
he is from Monterrey Mexico
and he says hello he's a Michael he's a
regular on this so we got this okay like
rehearsed at this point okay so what do
you have what should I say hola
um
he says yes and by the way I'm assuming
he's not offended by this because he
keeps writing it's writing in so you
know I mean he's he has some pretty
decent questions too so you know anyway
uh he says how do you deal with the
world that accepts so much pseudoscience
and Supernatural things but then
uh denies real science
um you know I mean I I I don't I don't I
don't know I I don't know how do you
explain that I don't know
where am I so Supernatural like religion
okay yeah so anything Supernatural
whether it's ghosts whether it's
religions you know you can say you know
uh uh uh bordering on extraterrestrials
uh you know where there seems to be this
willingness if not a willingness and
almost eagerness
to believe things that are mystical and
magical and you know that are uh you
know Fantastical you know we found the
remains of a dragon but you know the uh
when we Unearthed it it turned to dust
but we've got this blurry picture of it
right here that's a blurry picture see
like you know what what is it in US is
there something in us that makes that
like happen when we come back we'll try
to give Michael Shimmer a chance to
answer that question
uh we're gonna take a last break and
when we come back uh Michael Shermer it
would tell us about his his recent book
A book that it sounds like like required
reading for anyone who
is a citizen of the world how about that
how's that for a prerequisite I love it
all right we'll be right back Star Talk
we're back start talk Cosmic queries
we've got long time friend and someone I
deeply admire Michael Shermer who's as
I've said the patron saint of Skeptics
on Earth and Across the Universe and
I've confirmed that Michael you can put
that on your resume I think of course I
got Chuck Knight Chuck we can find you
on social media yes uh Chuck Nice comic
uh you're there yes sir thank you thank
you and Michael uh what share with me
briefly your social media footprint
oh well on Twitter Michael schermer and
uh michaelshermer.com from my webpage
skeptic.com for the magazine here's what
the magazine looks like
for those who can watch bookstores and
skeptic.com that's right it's it's in in
well-stocked bookstores that have sort
of periodicals in them you can find it
there and I think Barnes and Nobles
among them you know and so so we left
off I think a very important question
Michael uh there are people who just
simply Embrace Mysteries and the unknown
and are you taking this away from them
are you are you just a curmudgeon and
and and you're no fun you know I want
there to be dragons I want uh I want the
aliens to have come I want all of this
why are you taking away my fantasies
well first of all doesn't the truth
still matter I think so and you know 500
years ago everybody believed pretty much
the entire world was ruled by demons and
gods and angels and so forth and witches
and I call it the witch Theory of
causality Everything was caused by
witches of some sort or another demons
and so on and you know diseases
accidents storms droughts uh starvation
it all had Supernatural explanations and
we didn't lose anything by getting rid
of all most of those there's still
Mysteries to be solved and here is where
the mind fills in the Gap with something
you know the god of the gaps argument
it's God or in the case of conspiracies
if it's a big event like no one who has
a conspiracy theory about the the yearly
flu epidemic that sweeps around the
world right but if it's something huge
like kova 19 or uh you know the AIDS
epidemic you know for a while that was
thought to be you know targeting the
black communities or the gay communities
you know by the CIA that kind of thing
because of Tuskegee
and other you know kind of shenanigans
the CIA was up to dosing American
citizens with mind control drugs as I
mentioned you know if the CIA could do
that maybe they planted AIDS in inner
city but no one has conspiracy theories
like that for again the flu or you know
antibiotics why are there no antibiotic
Skeptics like there are vaccine Skeptics
right it just depends on the effects and
the bigger the effect the more likely it
is you're going to get some some kind of
extra causal Vector thrown in there a
secret conspiracy a cabal you know is
the demons it was Satan something like
that so it's a it's a way it's a causal
explanation you know we want we want
explanations for things it's you know
uncertainty is uncomfortable and you
know as as discombobulating as it might
be to think that there's 12 people
called the Illuminati running the world
and doing a crappy job of it uh it's
even more discombobulated
it's even more disconcerting to think
that nobody's running in the world
nobody's in charge it's just mostly
chaos and complexity emergent properties
uh you know why why is inflation going
up well this guy says this and this
economist says that who knows
right it's you know it's like what you
mean no one's running the show it's just
us isn't that I'm sure you have a term
for this but because we have to blame
somebody or something okay what's your
term for that
well yeah I don't think I have the blame
game yeah okay how about that well
actually there is one you know so I call
this agenticity or intentional you know
the kind of hyper agency detection that
is we tend to see patterns in random
noise and Infuse those patterns with
agency there's somebody behind the
scenes making that happen right so much
of the world operates randomly there's
just a lot of statistical Randomness
that explains things but it's hard to
see Randomness right so you know just
take the stars in the sky that's what
Randomness looks like it looks like big
Dippers and Little Dippers and scorpions
and fish and horses and things like that
right the patterns of of Randomness
actually in our minds look like things
so if you get a random uh you know
cancer clusters as they're called you
know those are mostly just random but
people see the pattern of that somewhere
or the example I like to use is when
Steve Jobs first came out with the eye
pod and they had the random shuffle
feature where your music will play
randomly and people complain to Apple
saying well it's not random certain
songs come up more than other songs like
that's Randomness you know if every song
came up equally as well as every other
song you'd have to program that yeah so
Michael they changed that so now random
means randomly but don't repeat a song
until you get fully through the list
that option is not available
Chuck let's go lightning around here
this is our final segment we can slip in
okay here we go here we go here we go
um
um this is on internet influence this is
Steve Murphy hi Dr Sherman or Dr Titus
and Lord nice people can research a
conspiracy online and probably find it
uh find just as many articles that
support the conspiracy theory as debunk
it should Gatekeepers censor or flag
media supporting false conspiracies
Michael that's a whole freedom speech
thing but be quick yeah well my
lightning round quick answer is no we
shouldn't censor those ideas okay and
media companies can just tag them like
they are with you know vaccine questions
vaccine articles that doubt it you know
here's here's a good article that
supports vaccines the gatekeeper is a
gate tagger basically at that point
interesting I mean that's not censorship
that's just in more information is good
more information I love it I love it
label them excellent Frederick DeCamp
says this hello my name is Duchamp it's
a Duchamp no actually it's
d-e-s-c-a-m-p oh
okay so he says um hey I love this
podcast I listen all the time my
question is do you think that science
denying people will lead us all to
Extinction
Michael you can't say yes to that dude
you just have to say no and we'll move
on to the next question no next question
please
leave that Michael I know right right
part of me says he's packing up yeah
he's stockpiling food in his basement
um so Michael just to give a little
seriousness to the question uh generally
in my public rhetoric I say that I don't
mind what people think anything the
problem comes about if such people rise
to power over laws legislation and and
influence governments in society so what
do you do if if such a person gains a
following and then they get elected and
they do have such power
mm-hmm well that's why you should vote
right this is why we should have a voice
in a democracy like that that's all
really all we can do and try to keep
people like that out of power
um you know in a free Society they can
have a web they have their own podcast
or you know like an Alex Jones type
person he's unlikely to you know be the
uh the lead anchor on ABC News right so
you know there are those Gatekeepers
keep people like that out for a good
reason you know they're not following
the rules of rationality and fact
checking and editing that you know
journalism has so or in politics
hopefully but our political system is
you know it's not perfect so those kind
of people do occasionally get into
positions of power but not often and
it's you know much as it's fun to pound
on Trump you know he's not president
anymore Biden's in there so however bad
you think it was January 6 and so on we
still had a peaceful transfer of power
and things are still going along right
like they usually do
okay wow for now okay for now for now
yes right I'm not prophetic all right
all right Chuck keep it coming here we
go this is Connor home Connor Holmes
says hi Neil hi Michael hi Chuck
um I'm going to condense his question
sorry Connor uh is there any correlation
between education and not believing in
science uh I've found that my
undergraduate degree taught me how to
determine a source's credibility while
my graduate degree taught me how to
better understand the actual science and
its significance so clearly the data
show Michael yeah like high school
there's a whole section in your book on
this so why don't you just tell us where
you went there yeah so education
um does attenuate belief in conspiracy
theories and pseudoscience and things
like that
sat word
reduces the amount of superstitious
thank you thank you okay put it that way
uh and other irrationalities but not as
much as you might think right so having
a graduate degree is better than having
a ba and having a bachelor's degree is
better than having just a high school
diploma in terms of the kinds of things
you would believe that turn out to be
nonsense but not that significantly as I
mentioned you know smart people are also
really good at rationalizing beliefs
they hold for non-smart reasons and you
know they're subject to smart people are
subject to the my side bias confirmation
buys the hindsight bias and so on just
like everybody else so it helps but it's
not a cure-all okay okay and so it's
it's a is there any understanding as to
why it's not should we teach different
things in school for example well in
terms of Science Education yes of course
you know this uh Neil that it's teaching
how scientists think is probably is just
as important as scientific things of
course yes you remember that study
showing that some significant percentage
of Harvard grads couldn't explain why we
have seasons they thought it was how
close the Earth is to the sun right now
how did they get through Harvard without
knowing something it's probably online
it's it's a short educational video
called a private universe and it's a
freshly minted Harvard
graduates they still have their robes on
and they're asked uh you know how do we
have why do we have the seasons and
they're up there saying oh well because
the Earth's orbit around the sun is not
a perfect circle sometimes we're closer
and that's what makes it hotter and
there's a Harvard graduates and the
title a private universe is in your own
head you create your own world view and
make everything fit into that world view
and and you will speak with confidence
even not knowing that you're wrong
simply because it fits your world view
so thanks for remembering that Michael
that was an important idea made some few
decades ago the takeaway here people
Harvard a waste of money okay
and just to be clear maybe this audience
doesn't need it but we have our Seasons
because of whether our access is tilted
towards the sun right or away from the
sun because consider if we just because
what the Harvard graduates
embarrassingly didn't think about was if
it was summer because we were closer
that means it would also be summer in
the southern hemisphere that's right but
it's not they have the opposite run of
Seasons there so they were not thinking
this through okay so right that's about
70 000 down yeah I can tell yeah it's
really direct rays of the Sun from what
I learned from Neil direct Neil deGrasse
Tyson yes Chuck I'm going to get you an
honorary degree for for all of this for
what you've learned
I see we get a couple more questions in
go okay here we go Scott W Peterson uh
says
um Dr Shermer to answer the book
subtitle
um because they are not in fact rational
this is my point also thank you thank
you he doesn't need to answer that just
let's keep going then he says I was
thinking the other day that people hold
on the Fantastic beliefs in the face of
mountains of evidence to the contrary
because they uh do other to do otherwise
would mean admitting that they are wrong
maybe they're too embarrassed ashamed or
something else so is there a psychology
behind this that says hey look man I I
gotta stick with this game I got to see
this hand through I already bluffed my
way this far and now I gotta go it's a
poker game that's right interesting I've
left my way in left my weight in now I
can't back out I gotta I gotta go all in
right that would be an example loss
aversion you know where we are afraid to
give up on something uh that we're too
committed to because we've already lost
things
um uh and so you kind of chase after you
know bad money or stay in a bad marriage
or stay in a a losing uh business or
hold on to losing stocks because you
know we're already in so in terms of
beliefs the more committed somebody is
to their religious belief or their
political position or whatever it is the
harder it's going to be for them to give
it up so if you confront somebody say at
the dinner table at Thanksgiving and you
know and they they bring up climate
change or vaccines or whatever
conspiracy theory they're into you know
you can't just say you're an idiot first
of all you can't just say you're an
idiot to believe this right because then
they're not even going to be listening
to you and
but uh but you have to make sure that
when you're countering their beliefs
with facts that go against them that
that they don't feel like they have to
give up their whole world view like the
example I use if you give people a
choice between Darwin and Jesus and
they're Christian they're not picking
Darwin right he's not gonna he's not
gonna give them everlasting life so you
have to take that off the table uh and
just talk about Evolution as a science
and here's the evidence maybe this is
God's way of creating diversity of life
and so on and by the way Michael just I
want to say so everyone knows
um that's a very important component of
your book How The sensitivity that you
need and should have when you're having
those conversations otherwise it's Paul
you're adding to the polarization so you
I thought you covered that very well in
the book Thank you all right yeah listen
listen respectfully nod ask questions
right he's got a whole set of rules how
you how you do that which everyone
should read before Thanksgiving
definitely oh yeah
actually read it after Thanksgiving
because I love that argument at the
table
all right here we go this is the artist
formerly known as James Smith uh he says
hello all this is James from
Indianapolis here so Dr Shermer what do
you have to say to those flat earthers
out there do you think that people just
follow the skeptic train write down the
skeptical of misinformation is there
such a thing as Miss skepticism in other
words are people sometimes Skeptics to a
fault thank you have a great day Michael
that reminds me uh one of the skeptic
societies I don't remember which it
might have been yours but I don't think
so there's a button and it just says I
doubt it that was the only thing on the
button and then and saying they're a
skeptic and I just thought to myself
that's so uh
I I don't know that it doesn't allow
non-doubt uh so right right well that
would be nihilism or cynicism right
right like this I mean you have to
believe you have to believe things is to
get out of bed and get out the door you
know that the society's going to
function my car is going to start the
money's still in the bank you know we
make assumptions about the world that uh
otherwise you couldn't function and and
we do that for the most part I think
with science you know we most people
accept most of what scientists tell them
without themselves knowing much about it
it's only when it bumps up against again
like a religious belief I don't know
about that Evolution thing because do I
have to be an atheist to accept
evolution because I don't want to be an
atheist you know something like that or
you know if you're talking to a climate
uh denier or climate skeptic you know I
find myself usually all of a sudden
we're talking about free market
capitalism and the American way of life
and it's like how did we get from CO2
gases to capitalism because that's what
they're really concerned about right if
this is true then do I have to give up
this other stuff I believe absolutely oh
man that's just great very sensitive
okay I like that I like that guys I
think we're out of time
maybe one and more I guess no you can
buy his book buy the man's book well
okay that is a that's a no-brainer and
everybody who's here's this better go
get this book The Conspiracy and the
subtitle why rational people believe the
irrational did I get that why here it is
why the rational believe the irrational
right and by the way people have found
of course this spells out conspiracy but
people point out also spell c i a c i a
and also Soros
s-o-r-o-s and there's other patterns
Kanye West here come on I know wait wait
no I'm old enough to remember just might
have been just before for your time
Chuck Michael and I would Michael would
certainly remember this when people were
sure that there were messages on Ritz
crackers uh on the on the the salt and
the dogs crackers yeah and they would
all kinds yeah people nah nah nah now
let me tell you something I'm not going
to believe there's a message on the
brown cracker if there's going to be a
message on any cracker it's going to be
a Saltine
now Chuck you took that right up to the
edge you say if this message on the
crackers you went right to the edge on
that one Chuck
all right guys let's let's uh hope for a
a more skeptical future so that
Civilization can survive itself yeah
where we all have doubts and uh but with
folks like Michael Sherman running
around maybe there's some hope I would
say mike always good to have you uh
thank you Chuck always good to have you
too always a pleasure man all right Neil
deGrasse Tyson here for our talk as
macquarius as always keep looking up